-My first guest is
a very talented actor,
writer, and director.
She stars alongside Bill Murray
in the movie "On the Rocks,"
which is streaming now
on Apple TV+.
Here is Rashida Jones!
Ah! It's so great to see you.
-Hey!
-Oh, my gosh, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Happy to be here.
-Oh, it's always good
to see you.
Every time we talk,
you've either just finished
or started something
really cool,
either for work or for fun,
but it's always something like,
"Wait, what are you doing?"
You go, "Oh, I'm going to
write a script.
I'm doing a podcast
with Bill Gates."
Which is unbelievable,
by the way.
What have you gotten into now?
What is the new interest that
I need to talk to you about?
-I mean, I wish I could say
it was something epic.
But it's, like, gardening?
Is that epic?
-[ Laughs ]
No, but I'll take that.
That's real.
Gardening?
-It's real. Gardening.
-I love gardening.
I would love to garden.
How deep do you go?
Do you change outfits?
-I go deep, I change outfits,
I have, like, a hat, I have
contraptions, I have tools.
-Yes!
-Shovels and things.
-Shears.
Not like "Mommie Dearest" vibes.
Not, like, giant ones
but little guys.
-Oh, yeah, that's, like, hedges,
yeah.
This is more, like,
those little tiny clippers.
-Yeah, like little herb ones,
yeah.
-Oh! What do you grow?
Flowers, herbs?
-Yeah, I grow -- I have a lot
of herbs. I have vegetables.
I have a lot of different
kinds of lettuce and kale.
I grow French snap peas
and chives and basil.
The crazy thing is that
I have this plant called yarrow
in my garden, and I have
a gardening teacher,
and she was like, "Just so you
know, this stops bleeding."
And I was like, "Okay, alright.
Whatever witchy magic,
whatever."
-Yeah, I'll have a yarrow.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can't wait to stop
the bleeding with the yarrow.
And one night, I nicked myself
with a cheese knife.
-Are you kidding me?
I do it every week.
-Yeah, and I, like,
took the yarrow and I --
Swear to God, I was,
like, pouring blood
and could not stop.
Was like, you know, holding it
and compressing.
Nothing was working.
And I rubbed it on my cut,
and it immediately stopped,
and there was, like, a clotting
ring around it like this.
It was like magic.
Like, it freaked me out.
-What?! Yarrow?!
-I know. Yarrow.
-See? This is what --
I knew, I knew.
You always give me something.
I love it. Yarrow.
I'm going to start
growing yarrow.
-You have to 'cause
that's actually practical.
Like, forget about your palate.
That's medical.
-That's what I'm into.
I love it.
I have to talk about the baby.
Oh, my gosh, I mean,
he's so cute.
How great is it to get to
spend more time with him?
-It's pretty hilarious.
It's pretty great.
I mean, he's really, like, the
only marker of time right now
'cause everything else is
just, like, so subjective.
But, you know,
he's, like, becoming a person,
and I get to see the whole
thing, which is awesome.
-I want to know
how musical is the baby
'cause you come from
a musical family.
Obviously Quincy Jones --
we love Quincy.
Your partner is a musician.
You're musical.
Is he musical?
-He's not tone deaf.
So that's the good news.
-Oh, I like that.
-You know what I mean?
Like, I don't know.
Who knows what will be?
He has a very good sense
of melody and rhythm.
He's very into drums.
I'm gonna call Ahmir.
-Let's talk about
"On the Rocks."
You and Bill Murray,
Sofia Coppola?
What?! Dude!
-I guess that's a cool thing
I did, right?
-What?! Yes! You think so?
Now it's getting awards buzz.
Yeah, I think it's something
you can talk about.
Can you tell everyone
what it's about?
-Yeah. I mean, you know,
it's so weird
because it's like
instant vintage.
We filmed it last summer,
and we filmed all over New York.
And it's, you know,
the city's so beautiful in it.
It's such an important part
of the story that, like,
the fact that we did that just
under the wire before lockdown
is so -- it's like
immediately nostalgic,
which is such a weird thing.
But then it's also
kind of a movie about
a father and a daughter
relationship,
and, you know, that's something
that's very close
to my heart and Sofia's heart,
obviously, and, like,
having this sort of, like,
father that changes the energy
of a room when he walks in.
Like, that's something
I'm also very familiar with.
And then just, like,
navigating that relationship.
Being an adult through
that relationship is kind of
what the movie is about.
-Has Quincy or Francis Ford
Coppola seen the movie?
-Both. Yes.
-And are they going like,
"That's not me"?
-Yeah, they're basically like,
"That's Quincy."
"No, that's like Francis."
Like, neither of them are
willing to feel like
they're the inspiration
for the movie, which is great.
-But I mean, but they're like,
"Okay, cool.
I mean, we're cool,
but Bill Murray's cool."
I mean, Bill is
just the most fun human.
-The coolest, yeah, yeah,
he's so fun.
-That car chase, I heard that
sometimes he kind of went
off script and just
started driving around
where he wasn't supposed to be.
-Yeah. Well, he fancies himself
like an amateur --
Well, probably even more like
a professional stunt driver.
Like, he really prides himself
on doing most of it himself
and, like, would speak stunt
talk with his stunt double.
But he did most of the driving
himself, and I think part of it
was because he likes to -- you
know, he likes to pull a stunt.
He likes to make people scream
and laugh and feel surprised.
So he would, you know --
We'd finish the scene,
and then he would just,
like, bolt and, like, lose
the follow van and all of
our escorts and, like,
just rip up Tenth Avenue
and get us busted.
He got us busted once.
-No!
-We were fine because it's him.
Yeah, totally.
'Cause we saw lights.
I was like,
"Bill, we got to go back."
And I saw lights behind us.
I'm like, "That's not our guys.
You know those are not the guys
in the production, right?"
-[ Laughs ]
-And the guy was like,
"You got to get off --
What are you doing?
Get off the street."
Luckily we were fine, but --
-Yeah, you're like,
"That's Bill Murray driving."
And he's like, "Oh, okay.
Let me escort you
back to the set."
-Exactly.
"Do you need any gas?"
It's just like the movie.
-[ Laughs ]
-He gets away with everything,
that guy.
-You two together, that's great.
And Sofia is awesome.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rashida Jones and
Bill Murray in "On the Rocks."
Take a look at this.
-What does Dean have planned
for your birthday?
-He's not going to be here
for my birthday.
-What kind of guy forgets
his wife's birthday?
-He didn't forget.
He has a work trip.
But we're going to celebrate
when he gets back.
-That's not the same.
I traveled.
I never missed your birthday.
-Right, but you had
some other shortcomings.
-Like what?
-Thank you.
-Spasibo.
Alright.
I'm going to take you to 21.
Just do me a favor
and check his texts, will ya?
-Rashida Jones, everybody.
"On the Rocks" is streaming now
on Apple TV+.